[Music]
it was the horniness that was the
teacher I thought it was in the way of
my teaching I was like if I could only
stop being horny I could meditate and I
could find God fuck that shit
God is in the horniness the reason the
book is called comedy sex God is because
God and sex were so closely linked for
me when I was a kid I wasn't tempted to
lie or cheat or steal or certainly not
murder anybody though those were all
very easy sort of ordinances from the
church to follow because I wasn't
tempted to do them but like sex is it's
a biological pulsing organically
occurring fresh batch every morning
temptation that we all these 12 13 14
year-olds were being told was the thing
the sin that was keeping God basically
from loving us you know what I mean we
were all good to go to heaven but like
three sometimes four times a day
you're very tempted or in my case I
would succumb succumb to temptation and
that I felt terrible about it because
that was my understanding of God and one
of the reasons I wrote the book was to
try and reform that understanding of God
as this like basically a bully with as
Nadia bolts weber says with a killer
surveillance system who's watching you
and who really hates you he hates what
you are and wishes that Richard Rohr
calls it willpower Christianity is like
we can just like push these giant
boulders away and lean on them and be at
church and be like hey brother but like
really you're as human as anybody and
that that is a cognitive and spiritual
dissonance that is a heavy heavy weight
so he joked that the book is called
comedy sex God but most of the sex is
with myself because it was so
internalized and it was so shameful and
private so when I lost my faith because
my wife hears sex again my wife had an
affair so sex again sort of betrayed me
I was like trying to be a good boy and I
got married almost so that I could have
sex so I was playing by the rules
and then she broke the rules but even
worse it felt like God who was almost
like the Mafia like I paid him a fee to
watch my bakery you know if that makes
sense and then somebody threw a brick
through my brick bakery window and I was
like you didn't hold up your end of the
bargain so I sort of lost my faith and
then I really had to redefine what
sexuality was it was almost like coming
out of the closet as straight I'm not
trying to minimize how serious and how
difficult it can be to come out of the
closet as gay but I had to be like
announced to myself into the world like
I like boobies and that was hard because
you were waiting for lightning to strike
you down so the wonderful thing that
I've discovered about the universe we
don't have to call it God because I
understand and sympathize that that's a
loaded word but I see a universe that
uses these wounds and these these
traumas and these wrong programs in our
favor ultimately
so I spent all this time first
repressing my sexuality then I lost my
faith and then I went through a period
of like embracing it as best as I could
I I bought the Playboy that I hid in my
bedroom in a chair that used to belong
to my grandmother I cut a slit in the
lining of that chair and I hid this
playboy that I had stolen with my friend
Opie so that was two sins really and
then when I lost my faith I bought that
Playboy on eBay and put it on my coffee
table like because I knew that my psyche
needed symbols I was trying to outwardly
manifest a world where I wasn't ashamed
of being a sexual person so like a
swinger or like Burt Reynolds I just
kept or a barbershop just open-air
pornography which was partially healing
and then I tried having anonymous or
casual anonymous is not true I knew
their names they knew my name
so it wasn't anonymous and I didn't have
sex with a group of renegade hackers
wearing scary masks I was just having
sex with people that I had no intention
of marrying which if you can believe it
was a huge undertaking for me
and then so I thought that was sort of
healing myself but as I talked about in
the book there was something there was a
third step which was I had to learn to
irrationally love myself and that that
is the sort of love that I believe is
coming from the universal coming from
God whatever image you'd like to use as
indiscriminately as the light so I
didn't I didn't I went on this retreat
to see Ramdas who's this spiritual
teacher he wrote be here now and I went
into I was on a private basically a
hermitage living in his guesthouse but I
was alone most of the time and I was
wonderful I had this incredible
transcendent experience sitting with him
I was hallucinating just fucking crazy
and awesome even while it was happening
it was like it's happening I'm having a
mystical experience but then I would go
back to the house and in the morning
sometimes or at night I would get 10 out
of 10 horny hornier than I had been in
since I had been 15 and there I was 39
or something and I was trying to be
spiritual I was trying to meditate I was
burning seven to ten sticks of incense a
day I was reading sacred texts and all
the while I'm thinking about jiggling
asses and stuff and I was I was
embarrassed
it was so obvious my Christian my
puritanical shame psychology was still
in there playboys on the table and
casual sex be damned I hadn't yet opened
all the blinders in my in my soul for
lack of a better word and let the light
in so I I thought it was in the way I
was very tempted to just masturbate and
and get it over with which is how I saw
sex I always thought it is not something
to enjoy or to respect or to honor or to
just participate with I saw it as
something that you wanted to get out of
the way so you could get back to being
good or being holy or being worthy of
love so there I was on a hermitage
fucking horny like I don't know if
people can even remember what it's like
to be 15 and you're just like everything
is sex everything is sex and and I was
really tempted to
do something about it I I joke in the
book I couldn't look at pornography on
my laptop though the password for the
Wi-Fi was the name of my round us as
guru so I couldn't like type in the name
of a otherworldly guru and then go to a
fuckin I don't know X videos or whatever
I just couldn't do it it was all coming
in my face coming in my face it was all
being held right into my face so I had
this moment of surrender and break where
I tried to do what I had been studying
and what I had been telling myself I
tried to just love myself irrationally
people give out this sort of bullshit
kirkland purified water love to each
other it's it's conditional it sucks
it's low-grade it's well loved and I
want that top-shelf premium love and
that really is a thoughtless love it's
it's a love without a reason it's it's
not Oh
I'm horny Pete I love how human you are
or how conflicted you are or how good
you want to be or or how carnal you are
and virile it wasn't that that's
justified justifying why you feel the
way you feel I just tried loving it
because love is a place it's like a
state that you can enter into and you
just go everything just like I said as
indiscriminantly as the light I love
this too it's not God is over here with
saying frak instead of fuck and not
seeing r-rated movies and being nice
Richard Rohr points out the word nice is
not in the New Testament doesn't exist
we've lost the narrative we've turned it
into Lego and it was never about that
and I wanted to get into that place you
think this is a mistake
this my body sexuality the world the air
we breathe the food we eat the whole
thing is sex the universe is undulating
eroticism and that's fucking beautiful
it's not a mistake and and spirituality
true connection and
with the divine to me is not a
resistance it's not about looking good
or telling people that you didn't jerk
off in Ram Dass as Hermitage which I
didn't but the reason I didn't was
because I loved myself if I did or if I
didn't and it was in that moment that I
realized the pain and that embarrassment
and that shame wasn't in the way of the
teaching it was the teaching and I had
another just beautiful moment of
actually loving myself because I
realized I had been giving myself that
low-grade bullshit conditional love and
I realized if you want to feel that from
the universe it starts by giving it to
yourself not in the way I had intended
but I did give it to myself
[Music]